before we leave you we have to end the
show with some good vibes today's show
host kathy lee gifford is officially a
grandmother with her son cody and his
wife erica welcoming their first baby on
tuesday an adorable little boy yeah this
is sweet the baby's name definitely took
kathy lee by surprise after finding out
they named him frank michael gifford
after cody's father and of course kathy
lee's late husband football player frank
gifford who passed away in 2015. we love
this so much kathie lee couldn't help
but gosh all about the news while
speaking um with her friends hoda and
jenna take a look and of course we'll
see you next time bye ladies bye love
you girls
to the baby we didn't they didn't want
to know
they did it the old-fashioned way they
wanted to be surprised and
and uh so um they called me right after
they called erica's mom michelle right
after
and then uh we got in on the news and i
got to watch
erica hold the baby before uh the world
did and
cody was still sobbing i think i can't
remember we're just so grateful to god
that it's like there's there a greater
miracle in the entire world than
the birth of a child you know show me
show me a bigger one a better one a
sweeter one and this little guy i didn't
know what they were going to name him i
was surprised cody named him after his
dad oh really because cody knew what it
was like to grow up in the
uh you know in the shadow of a great man
and uh but i guess he you know he's he's
never gotten over really and he never
will
uh the loss of his dad at an early age
and he uh he was his hero and he still
is